alessandra just bring us up to date with
what you're seeing how many buildings
are left standing how much rubble are
you seeing in the very center of the
sound reaches a small town and you said
at the tunnel about 2,000 2,500 people
the center's completely destroyed some
of the houses on the outskirts or okay
they're newer houses but the historic
center is basically a pile of rubble and
you can see the survivors because you
can see the dust still on them on their
shoes on the cars on their hair and this
is a series of small little towns it's
different from the earthquake of 2009
does a similar place nearby but it was a
big feeding this is a bunch of pounds
that happens they could be destroyed
Italy's prone to earthquakes because
it's on a seesmic line are the towns cut
off what kind of research and rescue
operation are you seeing on the ground
unfortunately the towns are completely
cut off a few you can only go in by foot
because this is a mountainous region
there are bridges and some of the
bridges are harder looking good let's
put it that way we see cracks in the
intervals but actually all the towns are
reachable so you have a civil protection
agencies already coming in we've seen
helicopter ism they are they are pulling
people out and it is somewhat easier
just because the sheer numbers are not
what they were in the 2009 weekly have
you felt aftershocks yes they are
definitely aftershocks not as strong as
the first but the unnerving when you're
in a heel town with the ground full of
cracks definitely yes alessandro
earthquakes are cultural is well what
are quaking to Italy we know earthquakes
in Japan and other regions they've been
for decades and centuries in Italy but
what does this earthquake mean for the
people of Italy I think it's a
particular Japanese have happy very
strong as they feel seismic housing in
here it's not as common and although
Italy had had a lot of mistakes I'd
still be nothing had as violently strong
it takes a long time between one very
very white violent and another one and
so the people have just always managed
and I mean the pessimist about it also
the fact that the buildings that went
down today menu
we're from the Middle Ages some of them
were from the Renaissance so you can
survive with the earthquakes and they
sort of lived with the earthquakes it's
a different way of him but who knows if
this keeps up in the future they might
have to rethink their whole attitude
towards clicks because it's been more
often